HE JOINS US LIVE TONIGHT.
FIRST, AN IMPORTANT BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
>> THE PRESIDENT NOW IS REACTING
TO A FLOOD OF INFORMATION COMING
OUT ABOUT HOW THE DEEP STATE
TARGETED AND SPIED ON HIS
CAMPAIGN.
ON TWITTER EARLIER TODAY HE
WROTE, LOOK HOW THINGS HAVE
TURNED AROUND ON THE DEEP STATE.
THEY GO AFTER PHONY COLLUSION
AND MADE UP SCAM AND GET CAUGHT
IN A SPY SCANDAL THE LIKES OF
THE COUNTRY HAS NEVER SEEN THIS
BEFORE.
WHAT GOES AROUND COMES AROUND.
THE YEAR OF THE BOOMERANG.
YOU HAVE A CRIMINAL DEEP STATE
COMING OUT AT BREAKNECK SPEED.
IT'S HOUR BY HOUR, NEW AND
DAMNING, THE PRESIDENT SLAMMING
THE SCANDAL GIVING IT A NEW
NICKNAME.
THIS IS THE TIP OF THE ICE
PERKING.
>> WE CALL IT SPY GATE.
YOU ARE CALLING IT SPY GATE.
A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
I WANT THEM ALL TO GET TOGETHER.
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL WORK IT OUT
AMONG THEMSELVES.
>> BECAUSE A LOT OF INFORMATION
IS COMING OUT HOUR BY HOUR, THEY
ARE RACING TO COVER THEIR
TRACKS.
COMEY FIRED OFF TWEETS, FACTS
MATTER, THE FBI USE OF
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCES, THE ACTUAL
TERM, WE CALL THEM SPIES, IS
REGULATED AND PROTECTIVE OF THE
COUNTRY.
ATTACKS ON THE FBI AND LYING
ABOUT ITS WORK WILL DO LASTING
PROBLEMS TO THE COUNTRY.
HOW WILL REPUBLICANS EXPLAIN
THIS TO THEIR CHILDREN?
>> BETTER QUESTION, HOW WILL YOU
EXPLAIN IT TO YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN?
DID YOU HAVE A SPY IN THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN?
DID YOU HAVE A SPY IN THAT
CAMPAIGN.
HE CONTINUES, DANGEROUS TIME
WHEN THE COUNTRY IS LED BY THOSE
THAT WILL LIE ABOUT ANYTHING
BACKED BY THOSE THAT BELIEVE
ANYTHING AFTER MEDIA THAT WILL
SAY ANYTHING.
SPEAKING OF LYING, THAT'S WHAT
COMEY DID UNDER OATH WHEN HE
SAID HE DIDN'T EXONERATE HILARY
CLINTON WHEN THEY WERE WRITING
IT MONTHS BEFORE.
COMEY'S CORRUPT.
THANK GOD THE PRESIDENT FIRED
HIM.
HE CAN'T KEEP HIS MOUTH SHUT.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT TO FIRE
BACK AT THE DISGRACED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR.
>> I THINK JAMES COMEY HAS A LOT
OF PROBLEMS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE DID, ALL
OF THE LIES, THE TREMENDOUS
LIES, ALL THAT IS GOING ON, I
THINK JAMES COMEY HAS A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
AT SOME POINT, THEY HAVE AN I.G.
REPORT.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HE HAS TO SAY,
BUT I ASSUME HE'S COVERED IN THE
I.G. REPORT.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE LIES,
ALL OF THE FICTION, HE HAS A LOT
OF PROBLEMS.
I DID A GREAT SERVICE TO THIS
COUNTRY BY FIRING JAMES COMEY,
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE SAID
IT.
YOU GO TO THE FBI AND A LOT OF
THOSE GREAT PEOPLE WORKING IN
THE FBI, THEY'LL TELL YOU, I DID
A GREAT SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
>> MY FBI FRIENDS TELL ME THAT
EVERY DAY AND THEY ARE HELPING
TO EXPOSE THE CORRUPTION IN
THEIR AGENCY.
THEY WANT THE TRUTH OUT.
THE SOON TO BE RELEASED DOJ, IG
REPORT IS EXPECTED TO SHOW
CLINTON COMMITTED FELONIES AND
COMEY PUT THE FIX IN TO SAVE
HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN AND STARTED
SPYING ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WHERE IS THE WARRANT?
WHERE IS THE JUSTIFICATION?
FORMER BARACK OBAMA BUDDY JAMES
CLAPPER IS IN A PANIC TRYING TO
SEAY HIMSELF RUNNING FROM MEDIA
OUTLET TO MEDIA OUT LET TRYING
TO SPIN A FALSE NARRATIVE.
LOOK AT WHAT HE SAID WITH THE
LADIES ON THE VIEW.
>> I ASK YOU, WAS THE FBI SPYING
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
>> NO, THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING ON WHAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE DOING, TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF THE RUSSIANS WERE
TRYING TO GAIN LEVERAGE AND
INFLUENCE.
>> SO WHY DOESN'T HE LIKE THAT?
>>
HE SHOULD BE HAPPY.
>> HE SHOULD BE.
>> REALLY?
PEOPLE IN THE FBI WERE SPYING ON
HIS CAMPAIGN WITHOUT A WARRANT
AND LIED TO FOUR JUDGES, IS THAT
NOT THE DEEP STATE TRYING TO
DESTROY HIS CANDIDACY?
HE'S STRAIGHT UP DELUSIONAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT LETTING THE
LIES SLIDE.
HE'S TAKING THEM HEAD ON.
>> WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE
DOCUMENTS, I THINK PEOPLE WILL
SEE A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAPPEN.
I HOPE IT'S NOT SO.
IF IT IS, THERE'S NEVER BEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
CLAPPER ADMITTED TO SPY IN THE
CAMPAIGN YESTERDAY
INADVERTENTLY.
I HOPE IT'S NOT TRUE, BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE IT IS.
>> THIS IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE
SCANDAL IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT SHOWS YOU HOW PRE-TENG
IT SHOWS YOU HOW PRETEENG
IT SHOWS YOU HOW PRETENTG
IT SHOWS YOU HOW PRETENTIOUS AND
EGOTISTICAL PEOPLE LIKE CLAPPER
ARE.
THE WIND HAS SHIFTED THE
DIRECTION.
LIKE WE HAVE BEEN WARNING, THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT.
NOT LISTENING TO ME.
WHAT COMEY AND CLAPPER HAVE
DONE, I HEAR, IS ORCHESTRATE A
MASSIVE ABUSE OF POWER, THE
BIGGEST IN AMERICAN POLITICAL
HISTORY.
LOOK AT JOURNALIST CHERYL AT
ATKINSON, EIGHT SIGNS POINTING
TO A COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
OPERATION AGAINST TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN.
THE FBI HAD ONE.
THE OPERATION WHERE THEY SPIED
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WIRE TRAP FEVER, CHERYL ATKINSON
POINTS OUT HOW SEVEN TRUMP
ASSOCIATES WERE CAUGHT UP IN THE
SURVEILLANCE WEB.
YOU HAVE THE MASSIVE ABUSE OF
POWER, PFIZER ABUSE, LYING TO
JUDGES FOUR OCCASIONS.
USING A CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DOSSIER.
NATIONAL SECURITY LETTERS, THE
FBI BYPASSING ALL JUDICIAL
APPROVAL TO OBTAIN PHONE RECORDS
TO USE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
LETTERS.
THE POWER OF OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
WE SAW THE UNMASKING, 350%
INCREASE FROM KEY OBAMA
OFFICIALS MAGICALLY IN THE 2016
ELECTION YEAR.
CHANGING THE RULES IN
DECEMBER 2016, CLAPPER MAKING IT
EASIER TO SHARE INTELLIGENCE
ACROSS ALL OF THESE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THAT HELPS THEM COVER.
MEDIA STRATEGY, CLAPPER,
REPORTEDLY LEAKING DETAILS ABOUT
THE PHONY BOUGH AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER TO FAKE NEWS CNN WHERE
HE NOW WORKS AND IS PAID.
LEAKING SOURCES RUNNING TO PUT
OUT INFORMATION ALL DESIGNED TO
PROP BEGAN DIEZ AND LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND DAMAGE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE F.B.I. HAD THE INFORMANT
SPYING ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
COMEY HAD HIS FRIEND LEAKING TO
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" TO GET A
SPECIAL COUNCIL.
THAT WAS PROBABLY ILLEGAL.
THE BUREAU WORKING WITH FORMER
BRITISH SPY, A FOREIGN
OPERATIVE, CHRISTOPHER STEEL, HE
PUT TOGETHER THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER?
THE EVIDENCE OF WRONG DOING IS
INCONVERTIBLE.
THE FBI, DOJ OFFICIALS
DISCUSSING TRUMP CAMPAIGN CARTER
PAIGE SPRING OF LAST YEAR.
MAYBE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
GOOD TIME TO SAY, MR. CANDIDATE,
MR. TRUMP, I WANT YOU TO WATCH.
TR ARE PEOPLE WE HAVE AN EYE ON.
REMEMBER TRUMP SAID TO COMEY,
ANYONE AROUND MY CAMPAIGN, I
WANT YOU TO DO YOUR JOB.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THE
INVESTIGATION STARTED IN JULY
WITH GEORGE POP DO THAT
WITH GEORGE PAP DO THAT
WITH GEORGE PAPADO THAT
WITH GEORGE PAPADOPTHAT
WITH GEORGE PAPADOPULAT
WITH GEORGE PAPADOPULOS.
THIS IS GOING TO THE SPRING OF
2016, WHICH IS WHY CONGRESS
NEEDS TO SEE ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS.
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS, I
HOPE YOU ARE WATCHING TONIGHT.
JUDICIAL WATCH, FBI HATING LOVE
BIRDS, TO PRESERVE AGENCY
RECORDS ON THEIR PERSONAL
ACCOUNTS AND DEVICES IF THEY
HAVE NOT ALREADY ACID WASHED
THEM.
EARLIER THIS WEEK THE FBI
ORDERED THE JUDGE TO PROCESS
13,000 PAGES OF PREVIOUSLY
UNDISCLOSED E-MAILS.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT ARE IN
THE TEXT MESSAGES AND E-MAILS,
SEEING HOW THEY TRASH TRUMP
CONSTANTLY AND STRUCK AT THE
CENTER OF ALL OF THIS.
YOU HAVE SENATOR GRASSILY
RAISING A RED FLAG IN A
DISTURBING MESSAGE THAT SUGGESTS
THE WHITE HOUSE OF OBAMA IS
RUNNING THIS, MEANING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT INVESTIGATION
THEY ARE REFERRING TO, SO
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE UNREDACTED,
BUT THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
TRUMP.
ANOTHER STORY, CARRIE PICKET
REPORTING SEVERAL FBI AGENTS
WANT TO BE SPEEN
WANT TO BE SUBEN
WANT TO BE SUBPOENAED BY
CONGRESS TO EXPOSE THE
CORRUPTION UNDER COMEY AND
ANDREW MCCABE.
THEY WANTED STEVE MCCAIN
PROSECUTED FOR LYING THREE TIMES
TO THE SPECTER GENERAL.
WASN'T THAT WHAT INSPECTOR FLYNN
WAS ACCUSED OF?
NOBODY THOUGHT HE LIED.
IT'S THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
DOJ, NOT RANK AND FILE.
THEY ARE HELPING US GET TO THE
TRUTH.
IF IT WASN'T FOR THESE PEOPLE,
WE WOULDN'T KNOW THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE SERVING WITH HONOR AND
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
THEY ARE ASHAMED OF WHAT THEIR
FORMER BOSSES DID AND FURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ALL OF US TO GET THE TRUTH,
RELEASE THE DOCUMENTS.
IT'S PUT UP OR SHUT UP TIME FOR
ROD ROSINSTEIN FOR STONE
WALLING.
DEVIN NIEWN
DEVIN NUNWN
DEVIN NUNEZ AND TRE GOWDY.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU GIVEN
ROSENSTEIN'S TRACK RECORD, NO
WAY HE'S GOING TO HAND
EVERYTHING OVER.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BRIEFING AND
HERE'S WHY.
ROSENSTEIN WANTS TO CONTROL THE
INFORMATION BEGGING PAUL RYAN,
DON'T RELEASE THE INFORMATION
ABOUT FIZA ABUSE.
THIS WILL HOLD THE KEY TO ALL OF
THE SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
ROSENSTEIN HAS MORE PROBLEMS
THAN STONE WALLING TONIGHT.
LOOK AT WHAT LAW PROFESSOR STEVE
CALABRESE IS ARGUING MUELLER IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS THE GREAT
ONE MARK LEVINE SAID LAST NIGHT
CITING THE MAJORITY OPINION.
THE BASIC PROBLEM, MUELLER IS
MORE POWERFUL THAN 96 U.S.
ATTORNEYS.
HE WAS NEVER CONFIRMED BY THE
SENATE AND ROBERT MUELLER'S
APPOINTMENT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
RENDERING EVERYTHING HE HAS DONE
SINCE MAY 17, 2017 NULL AND
VOID.
WE HAVE HEARD A COUPLE OF
FRIDAYS AGO, JUDGE ELLIS III
DESIGNING TO SEE THE SCOPE MEMO
TO GIVE HIM THE ABILITY TO CARRY
OUT THE WITCH HUNT.
HE E ADVICE RATED
HE C ADVICE RATED
OUT THE WITCH HUNT.
HE CALDVICE RATED
HE CALLEICE RATED
HE CALLEDCE RATED
HE CALLED O RATED
HE CALLED OUTATED
HE CALLED OUT MED
HE CALLED OUT MUELLER FOR
PUTTING THE SCREWS TO MANNFORD
TO GET HIM TO SING.
SINGERS CAN ALSO COMPOSE AND
FLIP ON TRUMP TO PROSECUTE AND
IMPEACH HIM.
ROSENSTEIN COULD BE FIRED AND
SOON.
WE HAVE TO WAIT TO SEE WHAT
THAT'S ALL ABOUT.
ALSO TONIGHT, TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS HEADLINE FROM THE AMERICAN
CENTER FOR LAW AND JUSTICE.
IT WAS A FAVOR FACTORY, DEEP
STATE FORCED TO TURN OVER
THOUSANDS OF CLINTON ERA
E-MAILS, TWO ABOUT THE COLLINEN
FOUNDATION.
THE ACLJ STATING THAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WILL TURN OVER 30,000
E-MAILS BETWEEN HILARY CLINTON
AND THE FOUNDATION.
IT TAKES MORE TIME THAN YOU
WANT, WE ARE UNPEELING LAYERS OF
AN ONION.
THEY WERE IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION.
AS THE AP DISCOVERED MORE THAN
HALF OF THE PEOPLE THAT MET WITH
THE CLINTONS AS SHE WAS SERVING
SECRETARY OF STATE THEY FUNNELED
MONEY GIVING IT BACK TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
CLOCK IS TICKING FOR THE DOJ TO
HANDOVER DOCUMENTS TO CHAIR
CHUCK BLASESLY
CHUCK BRASESLY
CHUCK BRASSSLY
CHUCK BRASSILY ABOUT THE CASE OF
MICHAEL FLYNN, A MAN THAT SERVED
THE COUNTRY 30 YEARS.
GRASSLEY WANTS TO SEE THE
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO FLYNN'S FBI
INTERVIEW.
THE AGENTS THAT TALKED TO FLYNN
DIDN'T THINK HE LIED, SO WHY DID
ROBERT MUELLER CHARGE FLYNN WITH
LYING IN THE FIRST PLACE?
PRESIDENT TRUMP REVEALING MORE
ABOUT THE SUMMIT WITH LITTLE
ROCKET MAN.
WE SPOKE WITH THE PRESIDENT
TODAY AFTER HIS ROUND TABLE ON
MS13 GANG VIOLENCE.
>> JUNE 12TH, ARE YOU GOING TO
BE IN SINGAPORE?
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT IT, TALKING
ABOUT IT.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT THING FOR